jetzt aber mal eine echt gute nachricht
da diese problem ist endgültig gelöst
ist das teil ist das geil komplett und
es war so einfach unser bundestag hat
gestern beschlossen fahrverbote sind
erst ab 50 mikrogramm stickoxid
verhältnismäßig und nicht mehr ab 40
genial oder genial also der grenzwert 40
bleibt haben sie gesagt aber er hat
einfach nichts mehr zu bedeuten
es war ehrlich wer glaubt überhaupt noch
blöde grenzwerte er hier jedenfalls
nicht wenn grenzwerte dazu führen dass
menschen heftigste beeinträchtigungen
ihrer mobilität haben und
wissenschaftler in solch einer breite
sagen lass uns noch mal drüber reden
dann glaube ich ist es schon einmal
einen einen ein durchatmen zu machen
durchatmen machen
ist nie verkehrt es sei denn sie wohnen
in stuttgart
dann würde ich lassen oder essen oder
köln
egal ich sage mal dieser steuer ist
einfach unglaublich er hat zum beispiel
neulich einen brief an die eu
verkehrskommissar in violetter bulls
geschrieben und eine überprüfung der
grenzwerte für ganz europa gefordert
worauf die frau zurück geschrieben hat
kein witz erstens ich bin überhaupt
nicht zuständig das macht der
umweltkommissar aber wohl sollst du das
wissen du bist ja nur minister zweitens
die grenzwerte werden sowieso regelmäßig
überprüft aber woher sollst du das
wissen du bist hier der minister und
drittens deine komischen lungenärzte
haben sich verrechnet dubai um den
faktor 1000 ohne jede forschung bei
welcher home glaubt solchen leuten das
heißt sie glauben was die sagen und
schönschreiben ja natürlich glaube ich
daran natürlich ich glaube aber es ist
ja sicher keiner von uns will
fahrverbote was den groko trick mit den
50 mikrogramm aber so ärgerlich macht er
lässt die autoindustrie komplett vom
haken ohne not warum diskutieren wir nur
noch über grenzwert oder weil sie nicht
die platzierung von messgeräten aber gar
nicht mehr über hardware nachrüstung die
bezahlen müssten in vielen deutschen
städten ist die luft immer noch viel zu
schlecht ja unter leben menschen
die atmen wolle er den helm nicht mit
tricks also außer mit dem hier der ist
wirklich gut
niki hat sich der bürgermeister eine
ganz besondere lösung einfallen lassen
schauen sie mal eine zweispurige straße
hier ist die messstation eingeblendet
die idee diese fahrzeuge dürfen nur noch
auf der messstation abgewandten spur
fahren
[Applaus]
ich finde es von der methodik nicht
schlecht so mache ich das auch da bin
ich wenn ich morgens gut drauf kommen
will dann stelle ich mich neben die
waage meine damen und herren ich habe
direkt bessere laune
endlich ein schlüssiges gesamtkonzept
für verkehr und saubere luft wer
wirklich schön aber ich sag mal wenn es
auch einfacher geht eigentlich ist es
ein staubsauger nur eben für feinstaub
dieser aufsatz filtert den dreck aus der
luft ein weiterer sorgt an den bremsen
der hersteller würde damit am liebsten
in serie gehen
ja natürlich meinen das wäre wirklich
ein tränchen andererseits verbraucht das
auto mit so einem klotz auf dem dach
natürlich deutlich mehr sprit hier
alternativvorschlag ich sag mal wenn
jeder deutsche nur noch mit
handstaubsauger vor die tür geht dann
haben wir die luftfahrt sauber mach mit
bei unserer aktion saugend für
deutschland meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
man muss schon ein bisschen tricksen so
und für die insgesamt nur noch zehn
städte in denen trotz aller tricks noch
fahrverbote drohen hat man in dieser
woche in rekordzeit einen neuen
paragraphen durchgepeitscht § 63 c
verkehrs gesetz erlaubt kommunen mit
mobilen infrarot scannern ab jetzt
stichprobenartig die kennzeichen von
allen autos zu erfassen die in
fahrverbotszonen einfahren das gleicht
man dann mit dem fahrzeugregister dem
zentralen ab und weiß wer quasi illegal
vereine ja angeblich wird für diese
überwachung sogar eine ganz neue behörde
gegründet geleitet von matthias matschke
auch wenn die daten nach zwei wochen
angeblich gelöscht werden das ist ja
schon ein eingriff in meine grundrechte
auch gott verfüge ich bitte sie können
sie ihren komischen big brother
fantasien gleich mal wieder einmotten
die man ihnen an der peter lustig
journalistenschule eingetrichtert hat
das bewegt sich selbstverständlich alles
auf dem boden des grundgesetzes im neuen
staatlichen automobil sicherheits
institut kurz stasi
ich fand den namen irgendwie ketsch ii
ich auch aber hermann steht das ist doch
ein wahnsinn allein der technische
aufwand warum zum teufel hat die gruppe
und nicht einfach die blaue plakette
eingeführt welche die können sie sich ja
gerne einführen die blaue plakette
das geht mich nichts an aber so was
passt einfach nicht mehr ins digitale
zeitalter und es waren sie nicht
umständlich
sie müssen erst die klebefolie darunter
fricke sehen sehen nicht dauert stunden
landkreis das so an der seite eine
katastrophe laut plakette er ist der
letzte scheiß außerdem die blaue
plakette diskriminiert pauschal
dieselfahrer bundes der einstieg
eigentlich in flächendeckende
verbotspolitik aber alle autofahrer
einer verbotszone flächen decken
fotografie denn ist keine
diskriminierung
nein warum der deutsche macht im schnitt
jeden tag fünf self es dann nehmen wir
den bürgern quasi arbeit an und ich kann
sagen die kollegin bayern haben damit
hervorragende erfahrungen gemacht an 15
standorten werden da in jedes jahr 100
millionen autos gescannt und da gehen
reihenweise schwerverbrecher ins netz in
den meisten fällen gehe es um
ordnungswidrigkeiten wie der verstoß
gegen die versicherungspflicht das sind
ordnungswidrigkeiten wie eine nicht
fristgerechte überprüfung also tüv
überprüfung von ohne diese ziele
was kommt dann als nächstes über die
durchgezogene linie vor
das sind ordnungswidrigkeiten ohne
gruppe gründete war die mittelspur zu
können eine blöde frau
für ordnungswidrigkeit übrigens genau
wie in die fahrverbotszone einfahren
karlsruhe gerade noch mal ganz klar
gesagt die ganze szenerie ist nur
erlaubt bei drohender gefahr oder
kapitalverbrechen welke die groko will
doch gar keine fahrverbote durchsetzen
wir dachten einfach diese diese krise
wäre ein prima zeitpunkt man ein
bisschen mehr überwachung in unsere
städte zu bringen
wer weiß wozu man die stasi später mal
braucht ja ich der wahnsinn was heute
technisch geht ich habe hier einen drauf
da kann man ihr publikum scannen und die
software erkennt dann schuldige
gesichtsausdrücke wer heute mit einem
euro 5 diesel gekommen ist so sekunde
da
[Applaus]
das prädikat beschlagnahmt selber schuld
matthias matschke malen oder belegt hier
für weitere heute schon videos und clips
verdachtsmomenten
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]